to the upward direction oh alright
anyway so we are gonna get going cuz we
got a good number of people in here we
got about 800 or so so I figure that's a
good enough way enough number two oh
stop doing good enough number to move
forward so does anyone have any
last-minute things they want to say to
me before we get too late for flights in
progress how many of those are
disastrous things where I'm moving
around the Sun why is my webcam all
wonky get up there okay all right now as
you all know I had this amazingly
designed ship that I did not name the
crashing explody
it's actually a modification of the
two-stage Lander and this top part here
is what we have to get on the moon in
one piece that's ski then one piece is
the key because this is supposed to
separate I actually need to adjust these
stages because I forgot that um these
are all wrong and these need to be
separated what needs to happen is this
stage separation needs to be in its own
thing and then this does not need to why
does that set to separate and fire and
blow them off in the same one that is
absolutely not what needs to happen the
last thing that needs to happen is the
the many one in here these four Rockets
oh no those are the solid rocket
boosters ah okay I got it and then the
solid rocket boosters those are what
needs to happen when you need a little
extra to get off the plane and then
there's one last last engine and part of
that small fuel take in there so anyway
we got this here this works I know it
works it looks bad but it works alright
it works it's good it's gonna get us
there not good but it's gonna do it
alright okay alright everyone okay there
we got holding on to your lug nuts
everyone good it cuz we're gonna launch
this bad boy maybe I could put more
Rockets on just to get us a little no
this is perfect it works cuz we already
know it works we just need to get it to
the moon that's basically the main
problem here and I'm actually I forgot
something here I need to step out for a
second let me save this actually let's
name it I dub thee O the Whammy
KaBlam II not the crash from exploding
I doubt V the Whammy KaBlam II which
shall be the grease I need to turn off
or turn down the the other sounds cuz
when it launches it's gonna be really
[ __ ] loud and I don't need that to
happen so you spacecraft you shut the F
up ambiance you can go down to just a
little bit of music voices oh no where
voices come from apply okay so now it's
not gonna definite case you didn't know
giant rockets firing or loud okay I'm
walking it I'm talking high walkie
talkie is it an integral vison allow our
soldiers to communicate in the field
what's it called the walkie-talkie oh
yeah walkie-talkie look I'm walkie and
I'm talkie what's just one call the
Whammy KaBlam me
what's a rooty tooty a man shootie
there's a crashing exploding I want to
see what what did I have is the crashing
explody I've totally forgotten well that
doesn't look that dangerous that is
hardly crashing exploding material that
actually looks like a pretty good ship
not to toot my own horn but I think that
actually worked for something I just
can't remember what I think that I think
this ship is currently in orbit around
the Sun I believe so I'm pretty sure
this particular ship is in orbit around
the Sun okay yeah getting out of that
one not using that whole here's another
there's so many crashing explode YZ oh
my god is this the one did I save this I
will I'll be shocked if I saved this did
I actually oh my god my game is all
lagging I this is the one isn't it it
had 600 parts in it haha it's the one oh
my god I saved it why did I save this
I put struts on it I forgot I put struts
on it oh my god it's here and with
struts does this actually work I don't
know I remember I wanted to see if I
could actually get it to fire I got a
launch this thing my whole game is gonna
just lag unbelievably so so bear with me
for like through the lag cuz there is no
possible way that this works guys
there's no possible way and even if it
does there's nothing to be done with it
because it's it's just a giant rocket
there is no second stage there's one
stage and that one stage is wrong and
someone corrected me it's not 60 um it's
like 120 I forget how many there
actually are on here oh let's go over
today we don't want to launch this at
the night oh oh no I forgot
I can't accelerate time with this
because it's so unstable
I just got along we're gonna do a night
launch get ready everybody
crank it away at 12:00 or two
frames/second skubish
and oh it's holding together it's
tilting there is no SAS on here even if
there was I don't think it would matter
I didn't put an SAS on this that's not
good that's not good
I mean it's flying but that's not good
don't the main sail engines can adjust
themselves so if I actually do put an
SAS on here they should be able to
adjust themselves so that they would
actually work I mean work but if I if I
put it if I put an SAS on there what is
that what what could possibly be over in
the distance over there
what what could possibly be over in the
distance I don't know but anyway so yeah
it's now that's not a good thing that's
not good look at look at the colorful
arc and they're overheating now this is
not I guys think there's a probably a
way that this would work cuz it's
holding together it's just not got a
good trajectory not bad yeah it needs an
advanced SAS the the advanced SAS all
that does in case you didn't know all it
does is automatically do the adjustments
and it is officially started exploding
you'll see it in a second it's still
yeah there goes there goes boom and
they're dead boom I'm still wondering
what the hell is this what is that over
there
catastrophic failure what the hell was
that huh it looked make it look more
like a penis ah that looked like a penis
to me I mean what are you talking about
that looked perfectly normal like a
penis what does the penis look like to
you what's wrong with your penis no all
right anyway we need to go back to the
drawing board with this one cuz
something is going wrong with that
we're not gonna get to the moon with
that hmm yeah but I'm wondering how no
that was there long before my ship
launched what how did that I don't even
know okay okay
anyway we're rethinking this we're
getting it somewhere else
machine for pigs a release date was
announced Oh My glob I have to look that
up frictional games oh it was not your
all bunch of liars it was not they
didn't they didn't it's not it's not
announced
Dave they troll this okay anyway enough
of that we got to get moving with this I
want to get to space
I mean I'll put this I'll put this on
the back shelf for the moment I'll put
this on the back shelf for the time
being well we'll keep it there but we
need to get with the blam iike blam me
cuz the Whammy KaBlam me is actually a
ship that can fly it can [ __ ] fly
like a pretty little butterfly can it
can fly all right how long is this gonna
last well until my other video gets
freakin uploaded which actually it's at
83% so it actually went faster now that
I'm last room so let's get this going
cuz we got to go we got to go cuz this
other video is getting uploaded it's Gil
got processed when it gets here but I
walked on the moon I remember as well I
was swimming in the I was driving in the
Sea of Tranquility hi son how are you
good alright let's launch this sucker
SAS on that's actually I'm gonna I'm
gonna just combine these cuz I know it's
gonna be launching yeah I know it's
gonna go up it's got enough - well yeah
yeah is that too loud for you guys how's
that whoops I've screwed up there how's
that going yeah yeah yeah yeah make it
louder
yeah these are the only Rockets I need
Clem Wow
enough of your silliness yeah okay
alright we're floating up in space we're
going into space like big whoop
what do I care let me see gee oh gee
does okay gee enable ah that would have
been that would have been great to know
how do I put him away on gee again okay
alright we need to start tilting OOP
that's good enough
whatever good enough rotating slightly
but who cares
boom zim zam okay Tim damn mm damn it up
the next stage caboose right
got some spin alright everybody loves
some spin how about you stop though
because not spinning is just as cool as
spinning oh lordy that is not looking
good
we're rotating a bit
too much go down go down
there's very slight adjustments there's
slight very slight oh God we're losing
control troll we have completely lost
s-- everything very gently stop turn no
yeah good enough okay we got it stop
betting okay we got it all right cool
we're doing good
oh we're know oh no I started the next
stage good thing I got him on any
meteors so that they don't do something
stupid alright we're going way too high
I'm a [ __ ] I'm I'm a dummy I'm a dumb
[ __ ] what I am we gotta do something
about this alright God do something
about this we've got to go anymore the
angular direction cuz we're going too
much upness gotta fix it to fix it
fix-it Felix alright okay now alright
good now we're gonna shoot ourselves in
this direction so that we make our thing
go more that way like this like that
it's got to go like that suck eat your
heart out Scott Manley there's a new
Kerbal expert in town with ant with
directions and arm gestures and whatnot
alright we're still going way too much
up that's not correct
you stupid kerbals we gotta go like
totally we're wrong it's wrong you're
wrong stop being wrong right we're gonna
go we're gonna do something drastic here
we're gonna point our thing down
slightly down cuz this is just does this
look right to you does that look like an
orbit to you is this is this even close
is that even close the answer is No
so go just go go that way go that way
Go Go doctor says I'm a dummy I know I'm
dumb she doesn't need to tell me I'm
dumb just look at me what do I know I'm
trying to do space stuff go go Callen
and Steven oh yeah good good job for
Colin Steve hey look it's some debris
floating in orbit well there's the space
station and there's my satellite but
it's still not right
this isn't right you dang kerbals you're
so stupid
get it going well I guess we're going to
the moon earlier than we thought and I'm
out of that stage that stage rocket is
out so I'm officially just running on
nuclear engine or I don't know
radioactive nuclear engine power so
anyway I guess now we decided we're
gonna go to the moon now right right now
right now we're going anyway where's the
moon oh okay us house like where'd the
moon oh it's blocked by the debris from
the last one so anyway we're kind of
off-kilter but one when we go to the
moon it won't make a bit of difference l
won't matter
duh Isaac Kerbal don't need no engines I
like that plague light i internet high
five boom hope you got it hope you got
if you die I'm not doing it again
alright heat yeah overheat I got it
don't worry I got it heats under control
if you see that it's not even a little
bit up there it's perfectly in control
I'm doing fine
we just need to get this to here I know
the purple and I'm not shooting at the
purple target but whatever the moon's
over there I need to just I'm just gonna
get it over I'm gonna
what about Cedar Point why do you keep
mentioning Cedar Point who cares it has
Top Thrill Dragster I went on it it was
great yeah I know Cedar Point great but
who cares doesn't not pertinent to space
space is all I care about right now
right now
I'm only caring about spice alright
we're almost there
3 9 14 21 and 0 okay so now our
perimeter our Paris lapses is not very
good but it doesn't need to be good so
all right now we can just accelerate
until we get to where we need to go
well let's not let's not hit those last
two I don't even want to get close to
those last two all right I want to get
closer to the luster
wooshii woosh key caboose key all right
all right
we're not gonna make it this time which
means we're gonna have to wait a lot
unless we do make it I don't know oh no
dr. issue you're right right last that's
doesn't apply here that doesn't apply
here I'm not completely missed if you
see the two-stage Lander debris
it says landed landed as in kind of made
it
maybe maybe come on what's the matter
with it
tell us what's going like brah can i oh
yeah big shout-out to my main man
markiplier he's dub s got that swag yo
woosh complete opposite direction
complete opposite of where we need to be
congratulations you're stupid no you're
stupid
I saw a flock of Muhsin there were many
of them many much Muhsin more bought
back ok and being a bit too silly
waiting for this to happen
I think I'll happen now gonna happen
next time and by next time I mean way
next time not even not even close to now
I guess I could have made my parry apps
it's a little bigger but I kind of want
to take this slow cuz I don't want to
overshoot my
all cuz it's very easy to overshoot the
goal how whoosh alright that's pretty
lined up so that the next time it comes
round they'll get their curl beans we're
gonna make it everybody yes cuz you
don't know who I'm talking about
oh did you see that see that Alright
lining up almost perfectly it's gonna be
beautiful it's beautiful
Kurt uh Brian Regan is one of the
funniest comedians stand-up comedians
alive I mean right up there with like
calamari is death oh that's not a good I
got every once and I'll get this thing
where I don't know if it's like some
doctor said I get hypoglycemic every
once in a while oh look at that it's
beautiful where I'm I get low blood
sugar for some reason I've eaten today
I get the hunger shakes you ever get the
hunger shakes well make up your mind
what are you doing you're gonna get in
orbit or what you're gonna get an orbit
you're gonna get you're gonna get into
orbit gonna get in orbit Bergen Norbit
how about Jack slappy what is that doing
what did that come from
oh is that this one okay alright so the
moon's coming in it's creeping up nice
and good so right here is what's it
doing hey buddy know what it's doing
like what is it doing can't even tell
dumb not right I'm not right here
something not right something's gone
wrong here
I mean I'm stupid but even I can tell
that something's not right so I'm done
smell right
Galla I just gotta see oh okay all right
we're good all right we're good we're
we're caught we've been caught we've
been caught everyone hold on whoa all
right hold up hold your horses grab on
to your lug nuts or your moobs I guess
if you don't have lug nuts just grab
them hold them tight get ready baby
we're going to the moon
crazy nuts all right we got to do this
right so as you can see we're gonna
we're actually already in a trajectory
to hit the moon we're gonna we're
actually we don't even need to make any
adjustments because we're already gonna
approach the moon so if you look at this
view and thankfully we are once again
there's kerbin right there oh that's a
beautiful shot that's a beautiful shot
all right anyway so if you look over
here woosh key well note that's that's
the kerbin again where's the dang moon
there it is all right
there's the dang moon I said the moon is
at the very bottom of our vision there
but it's still there so we are going
towards that son of a [ __ ] so if we
accelerate this a bit more you can see
that the moon is coming up quick well
not too fast too fast too fast too much
too much too much too much too much too
much too much all right so what we need
to do is we're gonna point our ship in
the very much opposite direction of what
duck why isn't my SAS turning off hey
guys this happens sometimes I why isn't
my SAS turning off you don't look so
good Pat bow
why is my eyes in my SAS turning off
it's not
mic by SAS it's not hey guys this is a
problem my dad's ass it's not going I'm
oh I'm fast-forwarding that's right I
can't turn off the up duh duh I'm stupid
I was just one up alright thanks guys
I'm dumb I know I'm dumb Oh Barrett me
me dumb all right so we're pointing our
ass towards the moon because we're
mooning the moon and what we need to do
is to make us ourselves not go as
quickly towards the moon this but we
need to get closer so that we can change
up what we need to do cuz right now
we're just floating through space yeah
it is poetic in a way I know we're
mooning the moon haha haha funny joke
okay that's close enough moon close
enough we're now floating one hundred
and fifty thousand feet above the moon I
got the hunger shakes I'm hungry I need
to get some food soon I've been
stressing over the nut load not
happening just not been happening so
anyway we're gonna do is we run into a
slight how much we got lots of fuel like
a lot of fuel but we're we got too much
fuel as a matter of fact if we were
smart I think I said this before we'd
have the other second set up as an
independent functioning system where you
could keep that in orbit like we could
make it in orbit and then do it so that
we could return but we're not gonna
worry about that we're just gonna burn
what we need to burn and slow ourselves
down cuz we are going to land on the
moon gonna do it we're gonna land on the
moon oh oh land on the moon moon get the
building to building first there's a
fish isn't building fish there's a booty
it's Billy fish all right cut you need
some water you all right you all right
done now
right I know over he got shut job
everybody I got I'm under control
I am in control this is in control I am
a professional Astro nurse I know I'll
be burning for oh you're right the
nuclear engine is heavy
I don't just want to waste the Landers
fuel I want to see if I can get off the
moon I would like to see if I could get
off the moon for now to let me do it my
way
and you guys sit in your little chair
xand you watch me be professional
maybe be professional oh I'm really
hungry guys I'm like my hands are like
shaking and I've got the hunger sweats
and oh my blood Sugar's probably really
low right now I feel good I'll get this
away when I was rating when I was rating
in back in Wrath and Lich King was doing
World of Warcraft and I would get like
just oh man I've just but I got to keep
going I got a plug on but do it whoo boy
all right whatever caring for it I'm a
professional gamer I will not stop to
eat I will carry on it must because I
get loopy when I'm hungry so it's even
funnier for you guys cuz I get I might
judgement goes and I'm you guys are like
are you funny ha ha the astronauts don't
look confident me I don't blame him I'm
about ready to launch one of them just
see if I can land on the moon with just
them in their backpack I think if I
could do that that'd be hilarious but
I'm not gonna do it now cuz I'm already
so close I'm not gonna ruin it not gonna
ruin it
alright anyway how far are we we're
about 80,000 up we're getting a little
way from our ascend whoo why didn't
anyone tell me about that
whoa Nelly whoa Nelly
whoa Nelly you stop there you stop right
there no one told me that I wasn't
adjusted correctly
cuz as you accelerate here's a little
science with markiplier as you
accelerate in the opposite direction of
your velocity vector you inherently
change your velocity vector because your
your speed at which you are approaching
the object is different you're actually
changing your orbit towards the thing if
you like if you zoom out and you see
this line coming through this line
actually cuts through it and there is a
quote-unquote orbit around the Mun that
is being changed and so the angle
narrows in and in and in so it comes in
the lines come together until it's just
straight up and down which is the idea
but that's not you know spot you know
not guaranteed to happen if you do it
wrong anyway times with markiplier
physics with mark
I just know I'm staring at this cuz I
know it's gonna go wrong I know there's
gonna Rome go wrong because even though
I know let's cut the end of this cuz
we're already close enough I already
know that it's gonna go wrong somehow
somehow I'm screwed up something okay
we're getting close to fifty thousand
feet
don't I'm I am very stupid don't get me
wrong I'm probably even saying some
stuff wrong so I don't know the
technical terms to it don't get me wrong
I am very very dumb all right we're
about to bail on the second engines
ready the nuke engine is gonna go and
we're gonna have a lot more control
Boosh
four walls bye-bye oh no I left it on oh
no I left it on oh no oh no no no it's
coming back now well wery docked with
the engine again oh god oh man I did not
think about see I told you I'm terribly
stupid but that was kind of Awesome bye
bye bye bye whammy could blame me debris
goodbye this is all going on YouTube by
the way this has got to be gone YouTube
Oh highlight of my flight and besides
the crash that's gonna happen so anyway
we need to fall a little more a little
more little buddy fall down you fall
down now okay what we're gonna do now
that we're above we're gonna adjust our
trajectory so that we are actually and
see what direction are we going in we
need to first we need to get some
control so let's the engines up
we're gonna slow ourselves down a lot
we're gonna do this very carefully see
we're practically going straight up and
whoa I have forgotten si azimoff so
down you can see the velocity vector is
like towards almost the pole but we're
not quite there so what we need to do is
we need to adjust the velocity vector by
come on by basically centering this
thing on the pole and now see it's
flipping around now and all the sudden
we're going up because we're we change
so that instead of going accelerating
towards the planet or going towards the
planet or our velocity is now going
what's going away from the plant that's
why it's just flip-flopped but by
locking ourselves on the pole we can
eventually as we fall down we go
straight down and not translating in any
direction get it get it okay
all right right now we've got no thrust
so basically um we're supposed to be
falling which we are we're falling very
slowly back down if we accelerate this
you see we start approaching carbon but
since we dropped the weight of the
engine we can do a lot more with
manipulating it so as you can see we're
getting a lot closer so we can bring the
engines up just just a pinch will
automatically start slowing us down and
I'm actually gonna engage the Landers so
I don't forget that later because I know
I'll forget that okay but you can see
we're basically locked in on the pole
we're actually kind of a little off of
it we'll walk too much all right let's
just not bother with that we're pretty
much straight up and down right now
I don't want to ruin it I don't want to
do anything to ruin it right now
this could be a picture-perfect landing
or just total chaos so let's just hold
on for dear life here
right and do this nice and gently nice
and we can throttle up a bit slow us
back down because you want to be
touching ground probably as close to
zero as possible I mean there's a very
little tolerance for hitting the ground
who would have thought you you can't hit
the ground that fast oh that's amazing
as you can see we're approaching a
little too quickly we're gonna ramp up
the engines a bit you can actually see
the details of the rocks now now keep in
mind I've never landed on the moon
before so if we actually pull this off
it will be quite amazing so slow it down
a lot just slowed down slow down
going nice nice and easy as you but him
alright so we can cut the engines now
cuz what we what we're going to do is as
we fall closer I think the moon is
moving beneath us so that's why I'm kind
of drifting off to the side so what I
want to do is just not mess with
anything we're just gonna hit the ground
as slow as possible
got it everyone got it
everyone got it got it hold on to your
seat hold on hold on to everything cuz
this is going to be a nail-biter hold on
to everything this is not gonna be good
because we are drifting way too fast
okay
damn it I got to correct this
hang on we're going way too much to the
side which means that we need to correct
oh my god I've ruined it I've ruined it
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
no no I was so close
stop going up I ruined it see I ruined
it
see we're going what okay I'm back in
like not ruined mode
well we're what's happening is the we're
going too far to the side so if you
think about it we're slowing down by
punching it a little bit to the side as
we try to correct our angular velocity
but I'm trying to think of ten things at
once while trying to get this and my
hands are twitching right now and
shaking so I mean it's not a good thing
but anyway we've done a little bit there
let's get back into straight and let's
land this sucker and whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa hey whoa whoa whoa whoa Oh get it
come on wheeled in reel in reel it in
reel it in no that's the wrong way and
we're on the moon we're on the moon yeah
we're on the moon yeah not right but
we're on there and I even hey the crew
hatches in the right thing we can get
him out of there yay let's go out on a
mission haha look at me look at him go
look at him look at him move this way
look at him go oh he's stuck he's stuck
haha he's stuck whoop jumpy
how do you jump with the go forward this
jumpy yes I hope you can survive that
look at him go moon party ouch oh I
think he broke his legs
oh you all right there little buddy you
don't look so you don't look so good I
think he broke his legs I shouldn't be
laughing but come on Pat bow really Pat
bow Pat mow he's got a smile on his face
you could see her kind of a grimace of
pain I'm guessing from his legs being
broken come on there we go ah there it
goes ah look at him see better now
on the moon look good but you didn't
want to go back anyway so the moon on
the moon yeah oh yeah look at me look at
me I'm on the map I walked on the moon
you'll never be able to get back but at
least you're here ha ha ha
all right well we did it everybody we
finally landed on the moon we landed on
the moon it was amazing I am starving
I'm gonna get some food but this is an
accomplishment for all man start digging
his grave that's really not appropriate
but this is an accomplished accomplished
meant from for all man Kerbal kind now
he's gonna go die over by this rock
whoosh we having fun Kerbal man you all
right Sonja thank you all so much for
watching I think my upload is finally
done so we played just until the upload
was done thank you for oppress our oh oh
our engages his little jetpack there
that's so cool
whoops oh he crashed Oh short-lived Oh
gravity still works on this planet it's
so strange get up get up you're not dead
yet you don't get to rest until you're
dead so we're gonna go and then we're
gonna how do you okay we're gonna try to
alright yeah there we go
a'right let's go into orbit again it's
going to space oh I don't think that's
working but we're going slightly up whoo
the Whammy could blame me a testament to
all of Kerbal kind alright so anyway I
got it I don't know how I'm gonna get
this guy down so let's just end the
flight here leave it with you no wait
hang on let me get this get a good view
of the Sun where's the Sun there it is
we're gonna end this here just pause it
there leave that memory for everyone to
see and so thank you guys so much for
watching I don't know what we're gonna
do next I'll try to find something
probably work on the space station try
to dock some things together as I get
this jumbo fuel tank like going towards
the space station and then all don't
like too much too much too much too
little too little too too much about too
much boom everything showers into orbit
nuclear bombs go off everywhere whole
world gets destroyed okay so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye